bonjour alexis quels messages ont donc
voulu faire passer les députés avec ce
refus de poursuivre les débats hier soir
selon vous le message d'une fatigue de
cette gestion sanitaire du coc vide qui
n'en finit pas de fatigués les français
et les représentants de la nation qui
débattent d'une mesure qui n'a pas être
débattu des citoyens naissent libres et
égaux en droits point le pass vaccinale
n'a pas lieu d'être il est inacceptable
et pourtant ils sont là pour en discuter
alors même que on le voit bien 77% des
français vaccinés 90% des français
éligibles vacciner et 200 mille cas par
jour qu'est ce que ça signifie et bien
que parce vaccinale pas sanitaire
gestes-barrières vaccin tout ça
n'empêchera pas le coc vide de continuer
son chemin le virus en a que faire de
ces mesures liberticides en revanche
nous nous n'en pouvons plus les parents
d'élèves qui doivent maintenant sonder
les narines de leurs enfants trois fois
par jour pour savoir s'ils sont positifs
quasiment et puis le fait de ne plus
savoir quelles vont être les nouvelles
règles ubuesque 1 qui changent du jour
au lendemain on a bien compris que
manger dans les trains c'est possible
parce que l'interdire était impossible
et stupide et les mesures stupide qui
continue je crois que on perd un temps
fou alors qu'il ya des sujets beaucoup
plus importants sur la table que ce faux
pas vaccinale qui est en fait un pas
vers un régime de la surveillance et de
la vigilance totale qui n'est pas
souhaitable d'ailleurs les oppositions
l'ont redit donc ils ont bien fait les
députés d'aller se coucher hier soir et
de dormir et de se reposer aujourd'hui
une seule chose devait être fait c'est
de mettre à la poubelle une bonne fois
pour toutes ces mesures liberticides qui
n'ont rien de sanitaires et cette
gestion ubuesque qui dure depuis trop
longtemps avec maintenant la politique
indigne choisi par le gouvernement de
montrer du doigt les non vaccinés comme
boucs émissaires pour masquer toutes
leurs manquements tous leurs échecs
depuis deux ans c'est proprement
scandaleux j'espère que des partis comme
l ère où le ps vont se réveiller et
arrêter de suivre la majorité dans son
délire de vigilance qui n'a rien de
sanitaires à l'opposition s'est réjoui
d'un camouflet infligé à la majorité on
est elle affaiblit pour autant
la majorité déjà chancelante on à faire
un parti qui ne sait plus où il habite
même s'il a un très beau et grand siège
de campagne on voit bien que la
république en marche est en train de se
diluer dans la maison commune pour
préparer la candidature du président
macron la réalité c'est que avec le
nombre est bien cette assemblée peut
continuer de fonctionner comme une
chambre d'enregistrement des oukases un
des décrets de l'exécutif tout
simplement parce qu'il suffit de dire
oui et de voter là ce qu'il s'est passé
c'est sans doute un manque de
mobilisation des députés la ram qui vont
se faire taper sur les doigts par
stanislas guérini et le chef de l'état
sans doute puisqu'ils sont là pour
enregistrer les desiderata du président
choisit en conseil de défense sanitaire
donc heureusement qu'il y à une
démocratie encore un même si elle est
faible et
d'apparat parfois qui fonctionne
heureusement qu'on peut enrayer ces deux
ce bulldozer a broyé nos libertés qui
est le projet d' emmanuel macron donc
tant mieux si au moins un peu de bon
sens revient dans le débat et si le
débat peut avoir lieu parce que ce qui
est scandaleux depuis le début c'est la
vitesse avec laquelle le président veut
imposer ces mesures liberticides sans
jamais avoir un réel débat à la fois
philosophique ontologique éthique et
démocratique sur le bien fondé de ces
mesures qui disons-le encore n'ont pas
prouvé leur efficacité la cnil a demandé
de savoir si le pass sanitaire avait eu
d effet si les confinements avait eu d
effet aucune étude n'a été publié sur le
fait que ces mesures finalement n'ont eu
un impact que à la marge face à
l'épidémie ducobu et puis il ya ce
variant au micron qui change la donne
puisque même s'il est extrêmement
contagieux les données qui viennent
d'afrique du sud d'angleterre ou du
danemark sont plutôt rassurantes quant à
la létalité de cette souche donc voilà
de quoi mettre dans les cartons
définitivement ce projet de passes
vaccinale un peu on imaginer un
rétropédalage de la part du gouvernement
à présent au non ce n'est pas la marque
de fabrique malheureusement de la reine
ce qu'on peut imaginer c'est peut-être
un 49,3 l'entêtement vers des mesures
toujours plus ubuesque est dangereuse
parce qu'on l'a vu en rappelez vous lors
de la loi sécurité globale même si le à
l'époque le conseil d'état avait retoqué
toutes les mesures comme étant
anticonstitutionnelle
le gouvernement s'était enferrée paraît
sur la loi vient sur la censure sur les
réseaux sociaux là encore le
gouvernement veut toujours aller plus
loin avec cette majorité à l'assemblée
qui obéit et ne réfléchit pas on l'a vu
aurélien tâche et qui a quitté cette
majorité parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
débat en interne et parce que cette
majorité refuse le débat parlementaire
hier olivier ferrand ne répondait à
aucune des questions qui lui étaient
posées il répondait soit par le mépris
soit par les petites blagues ou la
phrase d'à côté mais jamais avec des
réponses sur ces chiffres et qui aurait
pu aider les français à comprendre ce
qu'il se passe et pourquoi le
gouvernement choisi ce mode de
gouvernance donc la reine n'a jamais
fait amende honorable n'avoue jamais ses
erreurs et continue tel un rhinocéros
qui fonce droit vers la souche morte
d'un arbre pour y aller parce que il
n'ya plus rien d'autre à faire
malheureusement que foncer droit dans le
vide c'est une campagne présidentielle
qui commence et donc se dédire en début
de campagne serait terrible pour la
reine mais en même temps continuer dans
des mesures liberticides qui fatiguent
épuise les français je ne crois pas que
ce soit une stratégie gagnante merci
beaucoup à alexis c'était à l'édito
politique ce matin sur rtl france